so let's talk this movie i'm assuming
you had fun with it uh i mean it's a
it's a new teen comedy i feel like
everybody needs this type of stuff right
now the vibe of the film feels good and
interesting and it just feels like
something that's been missing from a lot
of projects we've seen why did you want
to be a part of this thing why did you
guys why did you want to be part of
bringing this picture to life other than
it being super fun in my character being
a badass
i think it's just really cool it's very
educational and it kind of is flipping
the narrative it's the first movie i've
seen i mean i know that there's some
i've never actually watched sex in the
city and i know that that's like the
only other
thing i know of where the narrative has
been flipped um for women expressing
their sexuality and
not having to be like falling in love
and the movie ends with a kiss kind of
thing you can't
work in a vacuum
this is going to require physical and
mental stimulation
it's like
how wonder woman was given all this
training but it wasn't until she was
able to channel her mental power into
her physical abilities that she was able
to defeat her opponents uh
yeah sure but it was just really fun and
like my character wears combat boots and
listens to death metal that's how i was
in high school so so the film is like
this young lady who's trying to make her
first sexual experience perfect but uh
what what do you hope the viewers take
away from this thing what do you hope
they get from this story i don't know i
mean whatever whatever they want to take
away from it i think
equality is a cool message
that we can take from that and also just
not to take yourself or anything too
seriously teen angst first loves first
experiences etc were you able to tap
into that playing this character of your
experiences being younger there's this
one part
where
my character kind of expresses
some of her emotions about some things
that have led her to being the way she
is now and um that i definitely tapped
into like my experience with my first
love and junior high and
you know it took me five years to get
over that
now in in sex appeal avery's challenge
with creating an app go back to your
teen self i was trying to think about
this earlier what app would have helped
you navigate your life and get through
your teens what app do you wish existed
when you were a team if i could pick an
app it would be something that had to do
with like law of attraction 101 was
which
with like manifestation so not
necessarily like romance related just
more like spirituality universe religion
type stuff so avery's going through this
situation and kind of her family and her
friends it's kind of like a symbol to
help her i guess her friends are her
family how important do you think
it is to have that support of friends
that are like family and family when it
comes to navigating you know all this
all this chaos in your teen years i
think it's super important i mean like
as
a species we're very social creatures
we've always lived in communities and
tribes it's just very very important
like isolation can do a number on your
mental health and things like that so
having support i've especially in the
last few years like i've gotten more
comfortable surrounding myself with
women because i grew up with a single
father and like three brothers so like
i wasn't really around a lot of women in
the last few years i've
developed very strong meaningful
relationships with with very graceful
women around me and
um being surrounded by that has had a
huge impact on my mental health and just
feeling good about myself and just you
know having my girls with me you have
this movie you have the uh you had
american horror stories if you could put
the perfect actor on the perfect project
that would be the dream scenario for you
to work with what would it be for you i
mean anything with robert de niro would
be really cool
so i think he's so cool yeah that would
be amazing i'd love to see you guys
together that would be
incredible you said macaulay caulkin
helped you with your american horror
story audition has he seen sex appeal
yet is he gonna see it what do you think
how how important is it to have his
support through all this stuff and you
pursuing this career i don't know i
don't know if he's gonna watch it i
usually don't ask like the people in my
life to watch the things that i'm gonna
usually get a little uncomfortable when
they do yeah
i did ask him for that kind of help
because we were in the middle of a
conversation and he was on board
in the ahs family
so you know it was kind of like a casual
thing but i usually don't ask him about
you know guidance too much if he wants
to offer it to me great
but it's more so just nice having
that familial love you know
you